[Music]
hey jason austin texas hey aj what's up
hey dave uh george thank you guys so
much for having me on today i really
really appreciate it sure how can we
help um
well i'm calling i just started a
financial piece me and my wife started
financial peace university about three
or four weeks ago
uh we're on baby step number two it has
been absolutely great good
you know we're still working on trying
to get our budget
uh figured out and how that actually
works so i'm working with the instructor
there to try to help
with uh helping us understand it a
little bit more but the reason for my
call is i got a call today from a
company called adr
alternative dispute resolution center
and they said told they said that you
know they were they were going to be
their legal courier and they were going
to be delivering papers to me uh
tomorrow okay us explaining that
we
had a judgment against us from bank of
america saying that we opened
uh 1 263
and it was from they said overdraft fee
from 2007. does that sound like
something that happened
i vaguely remember to be honest with you
uh but i guess it is somewhat did you
have a bank account with bank of america
in 2007
i'm not sure but i i think i may have
it's been so long ago obviously it was
obviously very if i did it was very
briefly
it was very brief
in regards to having it but i guess i'm
calling what is going on in your life in
2007 that you can't remember who your
bank was
well i had uh recently just got uh
drafted i remember i had gotten drafted
um to play ball
and um oh you were paying attention to
nothing okay except i wasn't paying
attention
now that makes sense that makes sense
all right so you think there's a at
least a reasonable possibility that you
open an account with them and that these
overdraft charges might be true
yes sir okay so well when they deliver
it tomorrow if they really do that's
probably bs
but when they deliver it tomorrow call
them up and offer them a settlement
well the guy told me on the phone today
he said that once they deliver the
paperwork he said that i could no longer
call them in order to negotiate they
said i'd have to go to
i guess whoever the
company is here or the court and we can
do that before them that's fine
that's fine go to them
because i'm saying this isn't going to
be delivered
okay
i'm saying this guy's lying
okay i may be wrong i may be wrong but
what's the worst case scenario uh they
deliver the papers and then you call the
new people and negotiate with them
whoever it is if you have a bill
outstanding from 2007 wants some money
and they would love to settle with you
they'd love to take 500 bucks and make
this go away you got a little money
store it up you could come up with 4 500
bucks and make this go away
yes sir good well don't negotiate with a
doob on the phone and don't give them
access to your checking account either
under any circumstances if you settle a
debt no access to your checking account
to settle it and you must have it in
writing that the settled amount settles
the debt in full it can be an email
that's fine but no electronic access to
your checking account georgia's right